All right, so my daughter was eight years old when she was diagnosed with
Immigilablastoma, cancerous brain tumor, and we were alternative medicine
people to begin with, and I knew I wanted to treat alternatively, but cancer is
scary or at least I thought it was, back then, and I just didn't want to do it on
my own, so we found Dr. Conner's pretty quickly, and it was such a blessing to have
somebody give us direction, and I remember him being pretty impressed with
things that we had already done, but you know, his treatments made significant
improvement in just two weeks. Two weeks later, there was no sign of any cancer, so
I realized how scary it can be, and because my daughter was a minor she did have to
go through some, you know, some traditional treatments, but you know, the things
that they told us, you know, the oncologist told us that she would be damaged in
all these different ways. She's had hardly any side effects because of the
treatment that we received here at the Conner's Clinic, so in, you know, we had
intended to treat Sarah for a year, I mean that was the course of treatment when we
came to the Conner's Clinic, but I remember laying in bed one night and just
asking the Lord to cure Sarah quickly, and I kept on hearing two weeks, and it was
just like no way, and sharing up two weeks later, Dr. Conner said that, you know,
the cancer cells that he had detected previously were gone, and our other
alternative homeopaths that what she had seen before was gone, and then we went
and did a full brain and spine MRI and a spinal tap, and the oncology
department agreed that it was all gone, so I am so thankful that we found Dr.
Conner's, and in closing, I just want to say that throughout that whole horrible
process, we just felt like Dr. Conner's cared about us and the people here at the
Conner's Clinic cared about us beyond that of our normal doctor, and you could
just feel the love that he has for people.